on me disait ching chen chang
chinetoques la noah chi
on m'a demandé si j'avais un vagin serré
il est une idée reçue que les femmes
asiatiques auraient un vagin plus serré
que d'autres femmes
je ne sais pas j'étais exposé à ce qu'on
appelle l'hypersexualisation des femmes
asiatiques
parce que je rappelais aux autres
l'image d'une femme alors on me disait
tu es masseuse ou bien tu prostituées
combien ça coûte
il y avait cette image d'une femme
asiatique qui était au service de
l'homme je ne suis pas une carte postale
d'une femme lascive docile soumises et
je ne suis pas non plus un manga
exubérant avec des cheveux de toutes les
couleurs il ya cette idée que les femmes
asiatiques se ressembleraient tout vous
vous ressemblez tout vous êtes tout
interchangeables le fait de nous
cataloguer dans une même case de même
catégorie une catégorie sexuelle ou même
pornographiques
parce que ça existe sur les sites
pornographiques une catégorie asian
asiatiques comme s'il y avait un
supermarché et que j'étais dans une gt
inhalé en fait c'est vraiment une
marchandisation du corps de la femme et
de mon identité de l'héritage culturel
que j'ai pu recevoir et c'est cette
image là que les gens voyaient deux mois
ça c'était assez violent parce que on
est objectif si on est un objet aux yeux
des autres on ne voit pas comme une
personne humaine avec des sentiments des
émotions avec toute une gamme de
ressenti mais on est un objet sur un
marché le marché matrimonial
on aurait une valeur on nous attribue
une valeur donc en tant que femme
asiatique j'étais plutôt bien côté parce
que je renvoyais cette image cette
représentation d'une femme qui serait
souple docile soumises
c'est une imagerie qui est lié au passé
à l'histoire qui a été construite avec
des années de guerre d'existence de
bordel militaire en asie de références
littéraires cinématographiques et qui
ont nourri cet imaginaire qui
aujourd'hui mais projeter quand en tant
que femme asiatique on dit mais au moins
vous êtes désirer mais désiré pour qui
par qui et pourquoi pour quelque chose
que je ne suis pas donc ce départ le
racisme n'est jamais positif
il ne veut pas me mettre en valeur le
racisme est forcément quelque chose qui
nous réduit qui m'affecte et qui peut me
faire du mal
ce n'est jamais quelque chose qui
m'avantage j'ai des enfants aujourd'hui
qui sont dans une cour d'école à qui on
dit chen chang a qui ont dit ça le
chinoise à qui on dit shin top 30 ans
après rien n'a changé